students at more than 3,000 schools
across the country will walk out of
their classes this morning to protest
gun violence the 17 minute walkout is a
tribute to the 17 victims killed last
month at Marjory Stoneman Douglas High
School in parkland Florida yesterday
Florida prosecutors say they will seek
the death penalty for the accused gunman
Adriana Diaz is in parkland right now
with what the nationwide protest hopes
to achieve Adriana good morning good
morning many Stillman Douglass students
will gather across the street at the
football field for the walkout the
school's allowing them to do it but
wants adult supervision and doesn't want
any students leaving campus from coast
to coast today protests will unfold in
hopes that the shooting that happened
here will be the last over 3,000
students just walking out and leaving
class it makes a big statement Stoneman
Douglas students say it's their duty to
join a nationwide walkout a tribute to
those killed at their school one month
ago today students across the country
spent Tuesday preparing for the protest
which they hope will keep the national
attention on gun violence and keep the
pressure on politicians the young people
of this country are advocating for
change and we want something to change
now according to the youth arm of the
women's March walk outs are planned at
more than 3,100 of the roughly 133,000
schools in the u.s. most students will
leave class at 10 a.m. in their time
zone since the shooting Florida
lawmakers passed a new gun law for the
first time in 22 years but students
there wanna see changes nationwide young
people are getting up there getting
politically active and we're gonna hold
our elected officials responsible other
students are opting out at mastery
charter school Schumaker campus in
Philadelphia students feel the protests
don't recognize everyday violence in
urban communities it's not like the
issue doesn't matter because of course
it matters is its lives that just got
lost but at the same time we're not
cherishing all lives the father of
Stoneman Douglas victim elena petit is
advocating for a different approach on
twitter ryan petty encouraged students
to walk up to the kid who causes
disturbances in class and
how he's doing adding the hashtag
walk-up not out the local superintendent
released this letter saying that
students will not be disciplined here in
Broward County if they walk out now
other schools will be marking students
late absent or giving them detention if
they leave class gale all right Adriana
thank you very much we'll bring you a
CBS News special report when the first
student wall cuts began at 10 East or 9
central right here on CBS I like that
idea of Ryan Petty's